mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
auf dem kunstmarkt von morgen dominiert
die digitalisierung
und in der landwirtschaft der zukunft
springst die nachhaltigkeit
wir beleuchten die hintergründe
[Musik]
wir kommen nach den kulturplatz ja wir
stellen ihnen heute menschen vor die
auch ein jahr nach beginn der korona
krise für ihre vision einer neuen welt
brennen und das ist einerseits hier auf
dem hof rein biologisch dynamischer
bauernhof wo sich menschen für die
nahrung von morgen einsetzen
zum anderen schauen wir später in der
sendung auf den kunstmarkt wo menschen
neue wege finden sich für die kunst zu
engagieren
[Musik]
die menschen hier auf gut rainer
praktizieren biodiversität sie halten
kühe ziegen schweine hühner pferde
sie bauen getreide an früchte gemüse und
sie ernten und pflanzen im kreislauf mit
der natur dahinter steht ein
ganzheitliches konzept es beginnt beim
saatgut zieht sich weiter über den
vertrieb und endet auf den teller
die verantwortlichen nennen dieses
konzept landwirtschaft mit zukunft
[Musik]
ja die dominikanische eine ausbildung
zum landwirt aus china und ist der
emittent vom verein landwirtschaft mit
zukunft dominik die hand visionäre
ziemlich für sie ab 20 uhr ist klar es
sind also hauptziel fans sagen ja es ist
ziemlich dass meine andere in
landwirtschaft und währungspolitik hand
in der schweiz weil landwirtschaft und
somit asse was man jeden tag macht hat
nächster dem großen fluss alles eigenes
klima für diversität umwelt und mehr
sende meine vor der jungen generation
dass das erasmus andere und was muss ich
konkret ganz einfach seit muss
landwirtschaft und ernährung innerhalb
der planetaren ganz funktioniert das
nicht mehr brauche als dass es hat das
heißt mit weniger besuchern viel weniger
fleisch essen mit besser auf processing
kostet natürlich auch muss ich muss
besser geschützt werden und es wird es
bewusst sie es braucht eine
freiwilligenagentur und der it was a
blast und in der landwirtschaft
ziel wäre danach dass es filme
biolandbau geht wo die regeln befolgen
ich es dann realistisch dass
konsumentinnen und konsumenten tieferes
borken erlangen für das was sie auch ist
es hauptsächlich das problem von der
falsche rahmenbedingungen gibt das heißt
rahmenbedingungen für andere stimmen von
anderen verbunden dass es möglich ist
für alle günstig oder preiswert
biologische sehr ökologische produkte zu
kaufen
die daten sind zum einen dass das
dass es nicht erlaubt ist rohstoff oder
natur zu produzieren was heutzutage
passiert und darum so günstig kann
produziert wenn die presse wo im lager
sind sind keine schnitte war preis und
somit braucht es natürlich koste
wahrheit dass mir das selber verursacht
und dann sind die biologische über die
ökologische produkte eigentlich günstig
ist ein realistisches also dass magath
sich nicht für eine saubere des stefan
jetz ziel sie will warnen das gefühl
hatte das thema immer intensiver
produziert das ist dass man jetzt machen
und das gegenteil von dem moment wieder
extensiven moment gewissen bereichen
weniger produzieren aber dafür wie
importieren und das ist auch einfach
weil es gar nicht dass man einfach gute
zerstören die nächsten zwei jahre und
irgendeines fertigung tun das ist ein
anderer unbedingt ökologischem report
eva-maria verkehrsreichsten der serie
sehen also der verkehr transport ist
nicht so wie es hergestellt wird wie man
mit der bitte um gott sehr wenig in
vannes ökologisch allem hand in ganz
europa unglaublich viele flächen wurden
landwirtschaftlich braucht wird vor dem
sex in das produkt europäische flächen
beziehe aber natürlich auch es gar nicht
darum dass man alles importiert sondern
dass man ordnung wie es und
produkthersteller die schweiz verhandelt
dh wenn man weniger tierische produkte
herstellen haben wir viel mehr fläche
weil das wagnis oder hülsenfrüchte die
rugbymannschaft konsum ab
[Musik]
dominik was heißt auch in einer audio
reportage zu erleben zum sf schwerpunkt
mutig in die zukunft seine idee wird
dort einem reality check unterzogen
[Musik]
bevor wir hier mehr erfahren über
landwirtschaft und ernährung schauen wir
für einen moment auf andere menschen die
in ihrem leben neues anpacken und mutig
in die zukunft schauen
[Musik]
bis sehr gute live band city new york
gegner aber wenn man erbach neues lahore
das heim ist
[Musik]
so zäh mitterbach verhandlungssälen
begradigt langweilig wäre interessant ob
tor
[Musik]
als kräften vielleicht lautet und links
unglaubliche verdiente die richtige
musik svd liegend auf
und der druck sicher sofort das gemacht
[Musik]
haben wir doch
und junghandwerker geisterfahrer machen
der unbekannte erst die kinder
podcast.de erzählt die ort wohin zu kind
entwickelt es entstanden sind sagt rist
folge wo bedrohte um die heimische
tierarten
[Musik]
wer bestimmt wenn dir für den podcast
besprachen sie beziehen und nicht
sondern machen das muss also das können
wir jetzt eine zuhörerin und zu sagen
was los und das erst sie es nicht bis
zum rückstand ist zunächst immer ich bin
nicht in der korona krise habe ich fast
keine konzerte mehr gespielt dafür packt
wie die nachbarschaften der
sauerteigbrot und möchte gerne in der
zukunft weitermachen
[Musik]
die disco eigentlich vor meinen nachbarn
ich habe einfach so viel brot macht was
mir noch bei der bahn angefangen mich
sehr und erwarte mir geht es gut
es war liebe auf erste
das was sie gerade machen ist totale
leidenschaft aber wenn ich das würde
professionell machen musste sich europa
rund 120 blut aus dem kleinen backstube
das war auch ein ich glaube schon
[Musik]
ja das waren ausschnitte aus den videos
die unsere kollegen von der online
redaktion produziert haben
märz um saf themenschwerpunkt mutig in
die zukunft finden sie auf unserer
website und auf dem facebook kanal von
saf kultur
[Musik]
ja es ist politisch das ist das credo
hier auf dem hof rainer und es ist auch
das credo des kürzlich gegründeten
ernährungs parlaments dieser sommer sie
sind die projektleiterin dieses
parlament was ist das ziel
das ziel ist vor allem dass wir jungen
akteurinnen im ernährungssystem die
möglichkeit geben ihre stimme gehört zu
verschaffen
die sonst oft einfach untergeht und wir
haben uns angeschaut dass wir wirklich
eine diverse menge an menschen haben im
ganzen ernährungssystem also angefangen
vom agrar aber bis zum verkauf und bis
zu den konsumenten zu hause und das
wichtig ist dass wir uns das
ganzheitlich anschauen und alle diese
menschen der stimmen bekommen
wie viele menschen sind das heißt das
vergleichbar ist mit dem schweizer
parlament wir hatten jetzt kürzlich die
hauptveranstaltung des ernährungs
parlaments da waren über 50 personen
noch dabei die sich wirklich den ganzen
sonntag zeit genommen haben mit uns
zusammen zu diskutieren
wie will denn dieses gremium in
politische prozesse eingreifen wie muss
man sich das vorstellen also die idee
ist eigentlich dass die politik auf uns
aufmerksam wird auf unsere vision und
diese dann auf greift also wir möchten
uns gehör verschaffen einmal auf der
straße tatsächlich mit demonstrationen
aber auch durch diesen partizipativen
prozess des ernährungs parlaments etwas
vom wichtigsten ist ja die lobbyarbeit
wie muss man sich das vorstellen
vegetiert davor das geht weniger darum
jetzt mit einzelnen politikerinnen ins
gespräch zu kommen und im flur mit ihnen
gespräche zu führen sondern es wirklich
so dass wir so laut und so groß werden
möchten dass wir gehört werden müssen im
prinzip das ist einfach eine frage der
zeit genau genau und je schneller desto
besser
und ist es realistisch dass die politik
auf euch zukommt weil die politik für
immer eher langsamer aus der mensch auf
der straße sagen ich mache also die
aktuelle agrarpolitik wurde jetzt gerade
assistiert und eigentlich wäre die
dringend nötig gewesen um einige
veränderungen anzustoßen
jetzt hat die ständerätliche kommission
selbst gesagt es muss nachgebessert
werden
wir brauchen eine ganzheitliche
ernährungspolitik und wir arbeiten da
eben schon seit einer weile dran das
heißt eigentlich wurde unsere forderung
da schon aufgegriffen jetzt müssen wir
nur schauen dass wir auch das gleiche
meinen wenn wir ernährungspolitik sagen
aber tatsächlich kommen immer wieder
mehr menschen auf uns zu und sind so
froh dass wir diese junge bewegung und
diese junge stimme bündeln weil alle
sind gleich auf der suche diese stimme
irgendwo her zu holen und wir haben die
quasi auf dem silbertablett
da immer gerne
[Musik]
ja auch die kunst ist hier zu hause auf
den gut rainer und die kunst ist auch
unser nächstes thema hier in der sendung
das heutige wetter passt bestens zum
thema denn dem kunstmarkt hat es im
vergangenen pandemie ja ganz gehörig die
bilanz verregnet es gibt zwar einige die
kunst online und digital vermarkten aber
dort kämpft jeder für sich nun aber
strebt eine neue schweizer plattform
nach globalen dimensionen so sieht das
silicon valley von zürich aus in einer
ehemaligen autowerkstatt tüfteln fünf
leute und die 30 aller zukunft der
kunstbranche am tisch versammelt jung
mutig und selbstbewusst
die idee von artie in sogenannten events
also in virtuellen events sollen sich
künstlerinnen galeristen und kundinnen
treffen können wie bei einer regulären
vernissage soll der direkte als zu 1
austausch untereinander möglich sein
aber halt eben per app ganz eigentlich
vor jedem als tool ermöglicht dass sie
ganz einfach und ihre kunst ihre
physische space ufer ganz spannende art
online bringen und eben auch unter große
unterschied liegt mit ihr beziehen wenn
du online shop boys oder von online
galerie hast du dir andere menschen mit
ihrem ruhm sind
du hast mir irgendwie ein indikator lag
das gerät über anders dar
mein kollege arno grad da und wird das
bild schaffen und da unterscheiden wir
aus extrem social ist das schlüsselwort
und soll das alleinstellungsmerkmal von
artig sein
damit will das start up die starke
konkurrenz übertrumpfen hatte bis zum
beispiel hat in der pandemie online
hervorragend gewirtschaftet
allein im ersten halbjahr 20 20 spielten
die dortigen optionen umgerechnet 264
millionen franken
dreimal so viel wie im jahr davor und
auch gegen die kunstmesse art basel will
in deren online viewing versammelt
direktor marc spiegler pandemie bedingt
282 galerien schauen klicken kaufen
dinge schneller hat da die angedachte
app wirklich eine chance es gibt es noch
nicht in der welt dass du eine eine
plattform hast wo du eine community
heißt die den kauf katalysiert das gibt
es noch gar nicht
du kannst alle anderen plattformen
anschauen die sich gedacht haben sie
sind digital gegangen wenn du selber
unterbricht sind sie nichts anderes als
eine online schaut für kunst das weil du
alleine vor seinem kunstwerk steht
hinter kaufe ich kaufe ich nicht hoffe
ich kaufe ich nicht ich kann etwas lesen
aber da ist kein interaktiver gedanke
mit deinen freunden
probe aufs exempel außentermin für die
ard chefin die galerie maria bernheim
wurde von deren ausrichtung und
preissegment her bestens auf die app
passt kg möchte kunstwerke zwischen
tausend und hunderttausend franken
vermitteln
doch galerist nicolas bernheim wirkt
noch etwas skeptisch
die lösung ist es gibt klar viele
wettbewerber und es gibt sehr viele
interessante ideen ich persönlich finde
das ist noch keine perfekte
aber es ist für sie jetzt sowie handwerk
zu bringen natürlich meine einigem
ausgeschlossen
sarah schlagenhauf kommt nicht aus der
kunst sondern aus dem marketing macht
nichts sagt sie selbstbewusst um den
kunstmarkt zu revolutionieren brauche es
schließlich vor allem ideen und ausdauer
auf ihre apps sollen bis zum start schon
100 top galerien dabei sein sportliches
ziel treffen mit der galeristin barbara
seiler sie hat fest zugesagt weil sie
schon heute 50 prozent ihrer werke
online verkauft da wert der weltweiten
online kunst verkäufe hat sich im
letzten jahr verdoppelt auf umgerechnet
11,5 milliarden franken für sie ist klar
virtuell und social das zählt gerade
aber das interaktive das startup will
nicht nur galerien sondern auch
kunstschaffende auf seine plattform
bringen
und zwar global
die kunst verständige der truppe stellt
sarah schlagenhof einen neuen künstler
aus senegal vor
auch er soll schon bald teil von portal
seien erste welt trifft dritte welt ok
zeigt nochmal das ist auch gut dass er
quasi er sitzt in afrika und es wäre so
cool wenn er das alles online stellen
könnte bei uns und auf einen und
interessiert sie das will sie denken das
große geschäft worte für setzt gar nicht
also ich finde die idee natürlich
die idee interessiert mich sehr und der
demokratisierung south park hinter sich
sehr interessant ich war mir mit unserem
produkt ob es kurz machen aber mehr
waren fünf titel
das geht uns ganz groß wirtschaft wobei
es ganz groß wirtschaft wo es wartet man
das also durch startet meters planen
wenn der camí zürich und arrivierte
galerien mit neo sammlerinnen ins
gespräch kommen sollen ist das team von
art deal am werk sie nennen es
geschmeidig die kunstwelt
demokratisieren
ob das klappt zeigt sich im sommer wenn
die app auf den markt gelangt
wie kommt der kunstmarkt durch die
korona krise mehr zu dieser frage
erfahren sie in der sendung kontext auf
radio sf2 kultur in den augen
[Musik]
bleiben wir noch einen moment bei der
kunst genauer gesagt bei der digitalen
kunst bei werken aus so die
ausschließlich als computerprogramm
existieren
das gibt es schon eine weile aber bisher
gab es dafür keinen markt jetzt aber
sind akteure auf den plan getreten die
das radikal ändern
es ist eine historische krise
wegen corona meldet der bundesverband
deutscher galerien und kunsthändler
einen umsatzeinbruch von 40 prozent für
das letzte jahr dass die pandemie hier
besonders hart zuschlägt hat sich die
branche selbst zuzuschreiben sagt einer
der es wissen muss
die kunstmärkte haben sich eigentlich
nicht wirklich der digitalisierung
geöffnet wie andere industrien in den
vergangenen 20 25 jahren und obwohl die
instrumente alle dort waren haben die
marktteilnehmer die sammlerinnen es
immer sehr gern gehabt die objekte im
original anzuschauen
doch boll ist trotzdem optimistisch und
sieht in der krise eine chance
er ist überzeugt alle zehn jahre
durchlebt der kunstmarkt einen quatsch
elfter september dot com blase und jetzt
eben kopf 90 auf jede dieser krisen muss
der kunstmarkt reagieren für das corona
zeitalter lautet die antwort
endlich digital werden
man hat sich der instrumente besonnen
die da waren nämlich digitale viewing
roms oder online auktionen und hat
gesehen das funktioniert eigentlich ganz
gut das war der ganz große durchbruch
also mehr ebay und weniger event für
eine branche die doch nicht zuletzt von
ihrem glamour lebt wenn der auktionator
den hammer schwingt und ein raunen durch
den saal geht ob der exorbitanten preise
für meisterwerke wie salvator mundi dann
ist diese traditionelle kunstwelt ganz
bei sich in einem über jahrhunderte
etablierten und verfeinerten schauspiel
aus faszination emotion und ganz viel
geld doch wandert all das wegen corona
in den virtuellen raum verändert dass
nicht nur den kunstmarkt sondern auch
die kunst selbst wird 2021 deshalb zu
beginn einer neuen epoche der
kunstgeschichte michael mann alias bipro
ist der vorkämpfer für eine neue
künstler generation deren werke nur noch
auf dem computer existieren bereits seit
14 jahren stellt der grafikdesigner aus
south carolina jeden tag ein sogenanntes
everyday ins netz bilder wie tom hanks
bieten das schiff corona wales entstehen
innerhalb weniger stunden
der unterschied seiner werke zu den
klassikern der kunstgeschichte könnte
größer nicht sein
und doch oder gerade deshalb hat
winkelmann fans auf der ganzen welt aber
erst in krone jahr fängt er an seine
bilder zu verkaufen und wer zu der erste
crypto art millionär der kunstgeschichte
ende 2020 habe ich eine sammlung von 23
abs verkauft und dafür 3,5 millionen
dollar bekommen
wenn man bedenkt dass ich noch 5000
weitere bäder habe dann kann man sich
selbst ausrechnen wie verrückt das ist
so verrückt dass es bibel selbst kaum
glauben konnte am 11 märz 2021 wurde
sein bild every day is der first 5000
für 69 millionen dollar bei christie's
versteigert 69 millionen ich fahre nach
disney world 69 millionen dollar für ein
bild das nur als datei existiert der
entscheidende unterschied zu den
millionen anderen gips und mims die das
netz überfluten beatles werke sind nf
hieß diese sogenannten lift dies kann
man besitzen eine besondere
verschlüsselungstechnik speichert in der
block chain wem das werk gehört sie sind
originale und nicht kopierbar klingt
trivial aber erst so werden babys micky
maus animationen und pokémon variationen
zum unikat und damit auch für sammler
interessant da draußen im netz gibt es
zehntausende künstler wie mich und die
wurden von der traditionellen kunstwelt
ignoriert weil man ihre sachen nicht
sammeln und weiterverkaufen konnte aber
sind sie kunst
bedeuten die nif dies also das ende für
walter benjamins these dass technisch
reproduzierbare werke keine kunst sein
können weil sie keine aura haben dass
die aura perdu geht würde ich auch nicht
sagen was ist die digitale sphäre
betrifft da würde ich sagen hat man es
wahrscheinlich in die tüte gesprochen
mit einem anderen typus von aura zu tun
das ist natürlich nicht mehr die aura
des originalwerks
zu einem fan von bp und seinen
kunstwerken macht das die
kunstkritikerin aber noch lange nicht
ich habe das gefühl dass mir da
praktiken begegnen die gar keine
schnittmengen mehr bilden mit dem was
mich als kunsthistorikerin interessiert
dass es wie eine parallelwelt die völlig
entkoppelt ist von den fragestellungen
die in kunstgeschichte kunstkritik und
künstlerischer produktion in den letzten
jahren virulent waren deswegen würde ich
fast so weit gehen und sagen das sieht
für mich manchmal wie nicht kunst aus
ich fühle mich erinnert an ein poster
shop in santa op
eine kritik die bibel an sich abprallen
lässt
[Musik]
jeder der sich ein bisschen mit dieser
art kunst und ihren stellenwert im
internet auskennt und um die bedeutung
von digital kunst in der
zeitgenössischen kunst weiß sollte mit
diesen sachen etwas anfangen können
aber wer die bilder nicht mag der sollte
sich halt seine gemälde aus dem 17
jahrhundert ansehen das ist auch okay
meine bilder sind eben nicht für jeden
fest steht auch aus angst den neuesten
trend zu verpassen werfen sammler bibel
und anderen crypto künstlern viel geld
hinterher
der marktwert ist nie ein indikator
dafür dass wir es mit relevanter kunst
zu tun haben der marktwert ist sozusagen
ein aspekt was ihr aber auch sagen
können ist dass hohem marktwert auf
dauer sind ohne jeglichen symbol wert
nicht aufrechterhalten sind den lift es
also nicht mehr als ein pseudo
künstlerischer spielplatz für tech groß
und bitcoin millionäre oder findet die
etablierte kunstkritik einfach keiner
zugang zur neuen bildsprache der
internet kunst
auf nfc marktplätzen jedenfalls herrscht
goldgräberstimmung
ich denke wir befinden uns noch in der
anfangsphase dessen was leute mit den
nfs anstellen ich denke die leute werden
in zukunft sehr sehr kreativ werden und
sich ein paar umwerfende kunstprojekte
ausdenken
heute weiß ich nur dass wenn junge
künstler solche dinge bei uns verkaufen
wollen dann versuchen wir das und sagen
ja und vielleicht ist das der ganze
unterschied zwischen den auktionshäusern
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts und diesen
neuen marktplätzen das junge künstler
unabhängig von prestige ausbildung und
habitus eine möglichkeit finden ihre
kunst zu realisieren und davon zu leben
wenigstens bis zum nächsten crash
spätestens in zehn jahren
das war unser ausflug auf dem
biobauernhof rheinau ja eine einladung
an uns alle darüber nachzudenken dass
das was wir essen auch immer ein
politisches statement ist nächste woche
zeigen wir ihnen die grosse schweizer
künstlerin sophie teuber art in ganz
neuem licht und gleich jetzt geht's
weiter mit der serie vor sie werden
kommen sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
street los
[Musik]